[Música]
bueno dicen los biólogos que en su campo
hay personas que llevan bata y otras que
llevan botas me gusta la metáfora y la
utilice en mi campo en la educación yo
soy un maestro devota y hoy vengo a
hablaros de educación la educación es mi
vida llevo 20 años dedicado a este loco
mundo de enseñar a otros he trabajado
con personas analfabetas he trabajado
con niños pequeños niños no tan pequeños
adolescentes adultos y ahora
universitarios la educación lo tiene
todo para mí es una rama de conocimiento
perfecta todo tu esfuerzo se enfoca en
mejorar la sociedad trabajar con las
personas que más queremos todos que son
nuestros hijos
y en construir una sociedad mejor la
educación es algo que no cambiaría por
nada del mundo
sinceramente si algo más tiene la
educación son quijotes
los quijotes son esas personas que te
entusiasman que te llevan detrás que te
guían y la educación los tiene a cientos
casi casi diría yo que allá donde haya
un colegio en cualquier sitio que haya
un colegio hay un quijote que quiere
cambiarlo y de eso vamos a hablar hoy de
innovación y me van a disculpar los
compañeros de bata para un maestro de
bota la innovación es tan sencillo como
introducir algo nuevo ya está solo eso
pero madre mía qué difícil por eso yo he
recurrido a estos quijotes en primer
lugar me gustaría hablaros de una mujer
de una mujer maravillosa una de las
primeras médicos que hubo en italia
no solamente fue capaz de superar una
sociedad absolutamente machista que le
impedía a la mujer llegar a la
universidad se hizo médico y luego
profesora de esa universidad y consiguió
una cátedra y cuando estaba ahí alguien
le dijo maría vienes
y maría dijo que sí pero no penséis que
le llevaban a otra universidad o mejor
no lo que le proponían a maría era
hacerse cargo de una escuela infantil en
un barrio marginal de román
como todos se habrán imaginado cuando
hago un catedrático de universidad nos
proponen algo así decimos claramente que
si dejamos todo lo que estamos haciendo
y nos vamos a roma a un barrio marginal
a fundar una guardería seguro que han
adivinar apellido de nuestra
protagonista su apellido era montessori
y ahí tenéis una imagen de lo que ella
proponía para hacer una escuela infantil
tenemos a otros quijotes que me gustaría
nombrar y pasar un poquito por encima de
sus vidas y sus trayectorias porque son
importantes para esta charla y para el
mensaje y la idea que quiero transmitir
los años 30 manuel bartolomé cossío dio
impulso
las misiones pedagógicas y que eran las
misiones pedagógicas las misiones
pedagógicas era algo muy sencillo
recoges actores intelectuales actrices
escritores gente que pinte que haga de
todo eso los metes en un camión los
mandas a la alpujarra a un lugar perdido
a que lleven allí la cultura porque
están de misión pedagógica es algo
fantástico
allí veis la cara del efecto que
producía en la alpujarra ver una
película eso se lo debemos a un quijote
se lo debemos también a manuel bartolomé
cossío ya las misiones pedagógicas pero
tengo más
os traigo también a francesco tonucci
trato trato lleva más de 20 o 30 años
pinchando no sé indagando no si
molestándonos para que nos activemos con
sus viñetas aquí tenéis una maravillosa
y os recomiendo toda su obra pero no
solamente fratto nos daba viñetas en la
ciudad de funk o en italia ha puesto en
marcha el proyecto la ciudad de los
niños y lo ha extendido por todas partes
en la ciudad de los niños los niños se
reúnen con el alcalde y el alcalde les
escucha sus propuestas y en muchas de
ellas hasta les hace caso
os traigo también al profesor gupta
profesor gupta era un ingeniero en una
fábrica de camiones y decidió dejar todo
eso para emprender un viaje por la india
más rural armado con pajitas cámaras de
bici gomas y enseñar ciencia a los niños
tiene una charla ted maravillosa que os
recomiendo
me gustaría terminar este recorrido por
algunos quijotes con kenia que a kenia
es una profesora más ay tiene una de
esas vidas que inspiran a todos los
demás
una de esas vidas mágicas en la cultura
masaje la mujer no puede ir al colegio
tiene que abandonar el colegio un
poquito antes de terminar la primaria
que a kenia se empeñó en seguir
estudiando y lo consiguió no sólo lo
consiguió hizo secundaria y obtuvo una
beca una beca para ir a eeuu a una
universidad muy famosa de nuevo tuvo que
enfrentarse a los hombres de su aldea y
obtener ese permiso y lo obtuvo tuvo ese
permiso
y no sólo eso después de hacer sus
estudios universitarios volvió volvió y
volvió a su tribu masai fundó una
escuela para niñas también una
experiencia de vida maravillosa
y este soy yo
en esta historia de quijotes hacía falta
un sancho pues ese soy yo sancho
me gustaría ser quijote y los acompaño y
los admiro pero soy mucho más mundano
mi paso por la educación
bueno como el de todos los primeros años
son los supervivencia nada más luego
puse en marcha algunas cosas y me
salieron mal luego después de eso repetí
lo que habían hecho conmigo en educación
después de eso me desencanté me de se
enamore de esta profesión tan hermosa
después me volví a enamorar y caí en uno
de esos lugares mágicos unos lugares
donde todo es posible donde tienes el
equipo humano adecuado y la gente que te
apoya y te da y te deja hacer la
creatividad lo viene a hacer lo vi
crecer y lo vi morir y cuando lo vi
morir me viene al audi ma me viene a
audi ma a enseñar a otros todo ese
camino porque ahora soy profe de profes
en este tiempo he hecho muchos tfg es
mucho este fm llevo ya casi 100 lo cual
no es mucho con propuestas de innovación
hemos hecho propuestas para introducir
la realidad aumentada las impresoras 3d
la de aprendizaje cooperativo los
proyectos cientos de cosas
todas ellas tenían estos elementos en
común seguían tendencias estaban
enfocadas en motivar a los estudiantes
querían conseguir resultados
introducían elementos nuevos innovando
pero no soy el único ni muchísimo menos
hay revistas artículos doctores tesis
doctorales de todo tipo que están
hablando de innovación y sin embargo
algo pasa en nuestro sistema educativo
aún no sabemos muy bien cuál es el
impacto de todos estos jóvenes quijotes
con ideas tan apasionantes y eso es lo
que nos hemos propuesto medir aquí en la
udima con un grupo maravilloso con
natalia con veronica con almudena hemos
fundado en 2019 el hoy en el
observatorio de la innovación educativa
y lo que queremos es ver qué pasa en la
innovación en los centros escolares
porque sabiendo lo que pasa seremos
capaces de detectar necesidades y si
conocemos las necesidades seremos
capaces de hacer una innovación que
realmente tenga impacto
la primera cosa que medimos es la m que
hay en esta m metodología la metodología
ha cambiado esto que hacemos nosotros
cuando hacemos un proyecto innovación de
cooperativo de proyectos de gamificación
es real llega a los centros estamos
midiendo los las primeras respuestas
parece que nos indican que no tanto
también nos hemos centrado en la o el
lado de organización queremos saber si
la organización del aula y del tiempo
sigue siendo la misma que era hace
tiempo sigue habiendo aulas rígidas
donde los profesores pasan uno detrás de
otro o esto ha cambiado hay aulas con
otro tipo de mobiliario os adelanto que
lo que estamos viendo es que el aula
tradicional sigue siendo la dominante
también queremos medir está r los
recursos de esto hay mucho en educación
software
e impresoras como decíamos realidad
aumentada de todo tipo materiales
manipulativos se siguen usando no se
siguen usando los centros no innovan
porque no tienen recursos yo creo que no
tienen recursos pero su uso es muy
desigual
también tenemos la lae de evaluación la
ley nos pide que evaluemos contenidos y
evaluamos competencias que hagamos una
evaluación del proceso y una evaluación
final pero eso como se hace eso es
tremendamente difícil de hacer y
queremos saber si los centros lo están
haciendo si pasan de lo que ponen en las
letras en los programas a los hechos y
lo hacen en el aula
me parece a mí que seguimos con una
evaluación centrada en contenidos
demasiado final y en la que se evalúa
mucho a través de las mismas
herramientas de siempre por eso creemos
que tenemos que evaluar más
mucho más y en eso estamos estamos
evaluando más y lo tenemos en ese
acrónimo tan bonito él hoy está detrás
de eso saber qué está pasando
y eso nos ha hecho pensar los primeros
resultados nos ha hecho pensar y volver
a los quijotes porque ellos sí con mucho
menos consiguieron tanto más de lo que
estamos consiguiendo nosotros ahora por
qué
y nos hemos dado cuenta que las palabras
que estábamos utilizando eran erróneas
no teníamos que hablar de tendencias lo
que teníamos que hacer es ahondar en las
creencias que tiene cada uno sobre qué
es la educación y para qué sirve no
teníamos que centrarnos en la motivación
la motivación es algo efímero dura muy
poco conseguimos motivar a los
estudiantes demasiado poco tiempo nos
teníamos que centrar en comprometerles
comprometerles con su desarrollo
personal con su estudio
hemos visto que estábamos demasiado
centrados en los resultados y lo que
teníamos que hacer era cultivar una
innovación que cultive el amor por el
conocimiento esa es la clave
por eso yo creo que ya tenemos lema para
el año que viene no creo que tengamos
que seguir innovando introduciendo
elementos nuevos y creo que tenemos que
ir a transformar la transformación es el
futuro de la educación así que vuelvan
ustedes a sus quijotes vuelvan ustedes a
sentirse sanchos de verdad porque lo que
pasa en el quijote es algo maravilloso
sancho empieza siendo sancho pero según
va transcribiendo la novela y según va
avanzando la novela sancho coge muchas
cosas del quijote y aprende muchísimo y
se transforma en otra persona diferente
sancho no es el mismo ni en sus
creencias ni en su compromiso ni en su
amor por el conocimiento ni por supuesto
en su transformación por su
transformación muchísimas gracias y un
placer